where most of the stores here have a
much more retro feel look at that
there's plenty of Transformers oh my God
Gerald nakana boy is the best compared
to akirabara it's much more organized
and can still find a lot of cool and red
like the boss on the shelves at even
cheaper prices
and if you want to catch upon there's
plenty of that too and the variety that
we found is comparable to the rest of
Tokyo
mandaraki takes up most of the space
here and each store is dedicated to one
specific genre of item the scary about
this place is the model of trading cards
and guji sauce so got that wallet be
sure to check out either mongku finds in
other independent stores like all things
Totoro and even found Curious George I
like giant robots but all General
recorded was zoids and Transformers red
is the Gundam there were so many perfect
greens everywhere available